talk to me about nofap the online space
has got this different perception of
what it is a lot of people think like
the levitation and it's going to make
you amazing and everything and so when
you go from this like multiple times a
day to like once every three days you're
masturbating it's quite a big difference
it's called online which you're telling
you if you fap again you've lost the
benefits because that's so unhealthy to
tell young guys I've come across more
young men who have been pained by nofa
than who have just like got problems
with me and masturbation they get like
this existential crisis where now they
feel like more of a loser because they
keep failing no facts six years we've
been building up this habit you just
think you're gonna break the Habit just
like that with a lot of the things we do
that we don't like ourselves for doing
less than 50 of the problem is the
actual activity that you do most of the
problem comes from the story that you
tell yourself about the type of person
you are for having done that action a
lot of the benefits from going through
any type of personal development comes
from a reframing around capturing our
own agency to do with that particular
action very well said